Ariana Maddox breaks her silence
following her split from Tom Sandoval
warning what doesn't kill me better run
I am my own person and I have very
strong opinions of my own late Wednesday
night the reality star posted this snap
to Instagram wearing a hot pink and
green dress on a recent trip to Mexico
for her friend's wedding kicking off the
caption writing hi where do I begin
Ariana shares her most sincere gratitude
for the outpouring of love and support
she's received since news broke that Tom
her partner of nine years had a
months-long affair with their friend and
Vanderpump Rules co-star Raquel Levis
when I have felt like I couldn't even
stand you all have given me the strength
to continue and see me through My
Darkest Hours it's definitely not easy
but I feel like once you
start talking about something it somehow
makes it easier Ariana's post comes days
after Tom and Raquel issued their own
statements Tom writing on Instagram I
made mistakes I was selfish and made
Reckless decisions that hurt somebody I
love something I realized especially
with being with Ariana
most is that if you have respect for the
other person you respect their
intelligence their opinion their views
that really makes a huge difference you
see when people go to the dark side
meanwhile Raquel told E.T in an
exclusive statement that she deeply
regrets hurting Ariana now Ariana says
she is devastated and broken but she
knows she's not in this alone adding
that some of her closest friends are
also grieving this loss and reeling from
this betrayal there's been a lot of
people who have come and said that they
have gone through similar things they
don't realize that they're helping me so
much by making me feel like I'm not
alone Ariana wrapped up her message with
a cryptic warning what doesn't kill me
better run sometimes I just I it does
get hard because you'd feel like you're
obligated to speak your mind it's scary
it's a scary world of course Raquel
caused controversy on the current season
of the Bravo show for kissing the other
Tom Tom Schwartz following his divorce
from Katie Maloney I'm just trying to
live my life and I'm sorry if that
offends people but it's not going to
stop me from doing what I want to do how
would you describe the vibe of season
10. we've seen you know marriages break
up it's always been about a group of
people that are so inexp
and it's so so volatile now fans want to
know how long Sandoval's bestie knew
about the affair and on Wednesday night
Schwartz's ex appeared on Watch What
Happens Live and gave her two cents do
you think Schwartz was a pawn in all
this I I do like yeah part of me
believes that he was duped you think he
was duped by Tom by both of them Katie
also gave viewers an update on Ariana
All Things Considered she's in a really
good like headspace she's you know
taking care of herself
um I saw her yesterday and we're excited
she's excited
[Music]